Are you familiar with the emotional code? The emotional code is a book that's out there. They have a website and there's different tapping things that you do with the emotional code. It's part of
what was it called, emotional freedom technique, EFT. So emotional code stemmed off of emotional freedom technique. For people looking for help with emotional healing from
healing from healing. Could be attributed to their cancer. If so, do you think this is in line with Christianity or something outside of the Christian faith? No, I don't think it's outside of the Christian faith. I don't think this is, I looked, I read the emotional code book years ago.
I used to teach some EFT. There's nothing, do age about it. There's nothing, you know, anti-Christian about it whatsoever. It's literally tapping on different acupuncture points to stimulate different changes in your body and how you're neurologically connected to an emotion because you talk through a blockage in your emotions.
Take a step back from a neurological perspective. If I let's say, let's say, okay, let's use this example because everybody's probably experienced this. I remember when I was a kid, my sister made these homemade ice cream sandwiches. She made this the cookie part and then she got some ice cream and she made these ice cream sandwiches out of these cookies and she froze them.
They were delicious. I had one of them and then I ended up getting the flu. I don't know. I was like 10 years old, eight years old. I ended up getting the flu and I got sick and then I got stuck in my mind that I will never eat one of those ice cream sandwiches again because it was right after I ate those ice cream sandwiches and I picked it up this bug and I got sick. So it was there anything physiological about that ice cream sandwich that made me feel nausea.
I was thinking about eating an ice cream sandwich. Is there anything that thickened me with because of that ice cream sandwich that caused my sickness? No. So it was all an emotional tie. And from a neurological perspective, your prefrontal cortex makes emotional, makes neurological connections with a deeper part of the brain called the amygdala.
So that just stimulated this amygdala connection. So every time I saw an ice cream sandwich, my brothers and sisters were eating one of those ice cream sandwiches a week later. Oh my gosh, I just felt sick. I had to go the other home. I couldn't even see them anymore.
Now, again, nothing physiological about the chemistry of that ice cream sandwiches. It was physiological in my brain, the neurological connection of my prefrontal cortex vision, viewing the ice cream sandwich and firing back to the amygdala, this emotional deep seated emotional pain that I had because of being, you know, violently ill with the flu.
So it is with so many things of our life, we end up having these prefrontal cortex, that's the frontal part of your brain that is your coordinator of your brain, it's the executive of the brain, you view something that you decide what that thing means to you based upon past experiences that if you had a deep seated emotional experience with that thing.
That is rooted in that deep part of the brain called the amygdala, you could have a violent reaction when you view that thing.
Same thing if you were in a bad car accident, same thing if you, you know, you could, there's a zillion examples of this and you probably have thought of someone telling you my example.
Well, using techniques like emotional freedom technique and the emotional code it's simply stimulating different points on your body while you're thinking of that thing to help break that neurological connection in your brain and it really does work.
I remember a gal who was a patient of mine, this is probably 20 years ago and she was in her late 50s at the time and she came to one of my nice to have these weekly seminars and I was teaching on emotional freedom technique.
And she said I have to go to the dentist tomorrow and I have to get, I have to get knocked out every time I go to the dentist because I have this fear.
This deep, deep seated fear of dental work and we literally did emotional freedom technique so she kind of volunteered to be the example of this and she came back the next week said, I went to the dentist, I did not have to get knocked out.
I was able to get convocated I did the whole dental procedure and it was just amazing and this is this is since I was just a little kid because she had this horrible experience with the dentist which was like seven years old.
So this stuff really does work things that you know how our neurological connections in the brain fire back to deep seated emotional experiences are real and you can't belittle those things.
Now the psychiatric profession just meditates people to numbness so that they don't feel those things well, I guess that can't work too, but how bad is that for you using things like the emotional code and emotional freedom technique can be very, very beneficial and I don't think you know I studied a lot of this stuff.
There is nothing anti spiritual about them so the people maybe there are people that teach this stuff now that are way out of the new age spectrum don't don't just count that but in general the procedure is just straight physiology it's nothing wrong with it whatsoever.